on today's show we talk about teens and
social media usage
we talk about a marriage that's falling
apart and folks are getting resentful
and angry
we talk about the joys and challenges
and heartbreak of fostering young babies
stay tuned
hey what's up this is john and this is
the dr
john deloney show we tumble to the
ground and then we say
i think we're alone now dude that song
stayed stuck in my head man doesn't seem
to be
anyone around but now
dude what i'm so glad you're here and
you caught me in the middle of singing
it's such a good it's that song's so
good we had to put at the front of the
show today
actually me and kelly we're having a
little moment makes me feel good
not not that kind of moment we're having
a moment and we're singing together and
then james
cranks the show up so here we go so hey
welcome to the show
kelly's turning bright red and she
doesn't even get embarrassed but she
is now so give me a shout one eight four
four six nine three
three two nine one if you wanna be on
the dr john de loni show
you can sing some songs with us
trying to get away into the night
that's so rad tiffany man hey
1-844-693-3291
give us a shout or go to johndaloni.com
show fill out the form it goes to kelly
hopefully she will stop being bright red
by then
and then she'll be able to check it out
and get you on the show as a reminder we
talk about
mental health we talk about
relationships we talk about everything
on the show
uh whatever's going on in your life give
us a buzz and james kelly
zach this is a big this is a big there's
a big day it's a big day because this is
a big month
and we are in a world in a world
we're in a world where there are a whole
bunch of different
months and weeks and days there's
like it's like national pony day and
box turtle day and national hug a rabbit
day whatever
but this is huge ladies and gentlemen
i'm drum rolling
and i'm not a good drummer or a drum
roller i didn't learn my rudiments but
uh but listen
there are a ton of underrated holidays
but the month of may
has one of my favorites hang onto your
hats kids
it's national life insurance day and
it knife insurance a month and it may
not sound like the most
fun but it is important that is spanish
for
super important muy importante life
insurance protects your family
financially when you pass away and some
of you're like are you seriously doing a
commercial right now
yes listen this is a big month it's life
national life insurance month
so when you're not uh so it protects
your family when you pass away so
they're not dealing with money stress on
top of losing you
and i'm making jokes but listen i have
sat with
multiple people whose husband has passed
away whose wife has passed away and they
look me in the eyes with a very s
it's a very unique look it is a hollow
terrified look that says
i don't know what to do and i've had
folks tell me in the middle of the night
i'm gonna have to go to work on monday
because we don't have any money i've had
folks tell me i don't know i don't
i don't know what to do and in that i
don't know what to do is
i don't know if there's a will i don't
know if there is if there's life i don't
i don't know
i don't know what to do life insurance
protects
your family listen last week
i'm changing my life insurance coverage
here pretty sure my wife's gonna off me
and so i'm
changing the coverage i got blood drawn
last week
in my office they came up here and drew
my blood did all my
like a miniature physical here for life
insurance i'm doing it
you do it you got to get the right kind
of insurance
the only kind of insurance that we
recommend here at ramsey solutions is
term life insurance that's worth about
10 to 12 times your income
no whole life none of that nonsense you
can google dave ramsey on youtube
and find out why term life insurance
our free coverage checkup tool will help
you find the right term
life policy plus other types of
insurance listen
if you're listening to this show you're
listening because
things go awry in people's lives things
they weren't expecting
relationships falling apart challenges
with kids
challenges with schools whatever it may
be
things will go awry right having life
insurance make sure the people around
you are taken care of
when you're not here okay get the get
your results
your free coverage checkup tool text
checkup to 33789
check up to 33789 to find the best
coverage for you
all right seriously it's national
insurance month
take care of the people around you by
getting the right kind of insurance
all right let's go straight to the
phones after
my excitement around national insurance
month let's go to amy in kansas city
missouri amy what's going on how are we
doing
hey john how are you i'm so good how
about you
i'm struggling a little bit here uh oh
okay bring it on what's going on
okay so um my husband and i we have two
wonderful kids
um we really feel deceived and kind of
scared hey
um i'm gonna make sure i can hear it can
you talk directly into your phone
yeah there we go much better yeah yeah
okay so
give me give me a recap okay so
um my husband and i we're so kind of
deceived and scared um
our 14 year old has been sneaking around
on
social media deleting texts and
is being mentally influenced by a church
friend
and so we don't know if we've made the
reigns um i guess electronics in her
life too tight
and we kind of need advice on what our
next step should be
okay so recap here is
your daughter how old is she she's 14
she's a freshman
okay so you have a freshman who's got
access to social media
right she have a phone and everything
she has a phone
yes so she's got social media she's
deleting posts and deleting texts and
communicating with their friends
and you feel hurt and deceived by that
yes okay so you mentioned something
about a friend
that is participating in this in this
drama so what's the friend's role so it
is a church friend who's
13 so about a year younger and
um so just to give you a little bit of
background we've always told our
daughter
that we will always have the passwords
to
um her phone talking to talking to the
phone talking on the phone
okay there you go um he's never been
allowed to be on social media we kind of
found this
out um a couple years ago tried to put
an end to it
and we recently wrote a few texts
from a church friend that
was coming out for her saying that she
was bisexual
and just was kind of influenced our
daughter
and we immediately questioned our
daughter on that
and she kind of broke down into tears
and kind of revealed to us that she was
feeling pressured
so um that that's kind of a negative
influence but we've never allowed her to
be on social media
um and with school devices and with this
phone we've always
had access to passwords and that sort of
thing
so we're we're kind of just feel like
we're treading on
in water that we don't really know how
to handle all this
okay um so there's a lot
here but i i want to keep going back to
did you guys get her a cell phone so
yeah mistake one number one when she was
still in middle school in sixth grade
we got her probably the dumbest phone
ever we got
a track phone okay so it was basically
for safety reasons so
she was gonna come home from school be
home for 30 minutes by herself it was
basically
tech small dad's telephone and that was
it she couldn't john even laugh but she
couldn't
send us emojis on this phone she
couldn't download apps and we were
very content with it but but now she's
14 and she's got a phone right yeah so
now she's got a different phone
okay and once again we told her you know
yeah but but listen
these the folks who designed phones
the folks who designed apps the votes
the folks who design social media
the folks who designed text messaging
from the dings the volume
this how the dings hit
to how the apps work to the photos the
way
it the ease the way it reads your
thoughts and your minds before even
it's designed to bypass all thinking
and go directly into your
emotional and fear-based parts of your
brain
sure and so i'm going to hold your 14
year old and i might get some flack for
this
i'm going to hold your 14 year old zero
percent responsible for this
and here's why you can't expect a
child's mind
that is hardwired to find out where they
belong
hardwired to find out who's my friends
hardwired to find out where they rank on
the social standing
and you give them a box that has been
designed by tech people and
neuroscientists
to hack that part of their brain and
they get mad at them for not using this
tool correctly
okay it's the mom and dad's
responsibility to put up boundaries to
protect their kids
and so when a child breaks down crying
and says i'm feeling pressured
to participate in any sort of
conversations and here's the next step
the next step is somebody's going to
reach out and say hey i'll send you a
picture if you send me one
or the predatory grown men
all over the world who are scouring
earth for people just like your 14 year
old daughter
they're going to make her offers that
her 14 year old brain can't refuse
because she is a child and so when you
hand a kid
access to earth and earth shows up
access to the world
and the world shows up that overwhelms
and scares a 14 year old to death
and so yeah she's not making good
decisions but she's a kid
right it's the same reason we don't let
kids drive or smoke cigarettes or buy
beer
or buy guns because their brains aren't
ready yet a 14 year old has a
i mean you and i remember being 14 in
our little middle schools right
remember what a nightmare that was you
know what i mean
i just wanted to be cool like on the
seventh grade b team basketball
like team right and there was like 12
guys on that
12 kids on that team not to mention all
the kids on planet earth
right and so i would never begrudge a 14
year old from texting with her friends
and then hiding them or you promise you
won't tell you swear you won't tell
that's what 14 year olds do that's why
that's why they need us in their lives
to protect them i do
understand that that makes their kid
weird and here's how i know that
because my 11 year old came home a few
weeks ago bawling his eyes out
because he realized there's a whole
universe in his school
of kids on tick tock and texting and all
and he wasn't a part of it
and you know what i did um i don't know
if his therapist when he's 30 is going
to
thank me for this because he or she may
make some money off of me
i actually pulled up some of my youtube
show and some of my podcast reviews and
let him read what people say about his
dad
and just the idiots who just post stuff
and his eyes got really big and i said
it's my job to make sure nobody says
that about you
until you're old enough to understand
what you're getting into and that's why
we don't let you have it
and so um in my house we're scorched
earth on it man i'm just not going to
put that kind of hate and poison into
the hands of a 14 year old
and i know that's going to make my kid
weird and it's going to make him an
outcast and it means i'm going to have
to backfill that relationship right
but i do think it is really hard to put
a
14 year old in that kind of position and
then get upset that they're not using
that correctly
does that i mean and let's be honest you
know this right
yes so what what changed between
your your um you guys are really tight
on it with that track phone what
changed that you were like ah okay we'll
just give her this other big
bazooka of a phone
you know she's always been um we've
never had behavior problems with her
she's
a you know a great city and we've never
had issues with her so i guess
we decided that we can trust her and you
know she was post racist all my friends
have one
and we would reluctantly did it um
and hey listen i don't know how to
backtrack yeah
i love that that's a great question and
listen i don't want you to feel
um bananas 99
of the parents i talk to say what you
just said i know in my gut this is crazy
but i don't want my kid to be the only
one and what i'm calling on parents
is to stand up and be the only one
because what you're going to find is a
lot of other parents it's like an arms
race
a lot of other parents would be all into
i hear this with those video game
systems they walk in and see their kids
playing call of duty and they're like
ah there's a lot of murder going on on
this screen
but i don't want my kid to be the only
weird one and so
it's okay and and vice versa right and
we can we could do this all in and on
but especially with these phones and
social media and texting
and so here's how you backtrack you have
a hard hard conversation
with your daughter and you let them know
hey
we didn't feel good about this and we
did it anyway and this was our fault and
we're sorry for putting you in
we're sorry for handing you the keys to
our car and telling you to go drive to
the mall because you're 14.
and i wouldn't beat her up over you've
lost our trust and this
and all that man you put a 14 year old
kid in a position that's really
challenging for them to be successful
and so i would tell them i would own it
all and say hey we set you up in a
position to fail
we're gonna take your phone um uh
we're gonna take social media off this
thing we're gonna not
give you that kind of access to the
world we're gonna want you to have
friends over to our house we're gonna
love that we're gonna love on you we're
gonna be connected to you
um but we're gonna this one's gonna go
and she's gonna think her world just
ended right think you are taking cocaine
away from an addict
right right or beer away because that's
really what you're doing
and you're going to have to weather this
upcoming storm and the storm is going to
be you suck you're the worst appearance
ever why do you hate me you're ruining
my life all those things
and now you're playing a long game right
now okay the chances of you actually
doing this are very small and i know
this right i've been working with
parents for
almost two days no no no no no you don't
understand how much
people know is worried but we are 95
okay so so tell me this because this
this
question is going to help all 31 people
listening to this and by the way
we're way past that now so i won't even
exaggerate on this you're going to help
millions of people with this answer
you are already there in your soul what
is keeping you from
just walking in there and taking that
phone and smashing into a million pieces
and say i care for your heart too much
to ever have this conversation again
like what what is the thing holding you
back what do you think is going to
happen
i mean i guess i'm scared about
discovering that relationship we have a
great relationship with her
and i think she once
she's also a little a follower and not a
leader with her friends and in school
and i think i'm just fearfulness that
um we're just going to push her away
even more
you know and we wanted we wanted to give
her this responsibility and like he's
explained it was
too much we couldn't put out it it was
unfair of us to put that in her lap
so i that's what i guess i'm fearful of
is that
her shedding around all walls already
she's 14. there's a light to talk to us
about certain things already
right you know and this may be
an incredible opportunity for you to go
first
this may and maybe not but this may be
the first time she's heard you
go first and say hey i screwed this up
and i'm gonna have to do something
really hard i'm gonna take this away
and maybe if you want to be bananas amy
you can lean in and say i'm deleting
social media off my phone would you be
willing to do that for her
yes i would and so if she show if you
showed her delete
social media off the phone and said i'm
in this with you
and your brothers and sisters
everybody's gonna be off social media
and that's gonna means we're gonna have
to like talk as a family blah
and we're gonna have to figure this out
and i'm gonna do something so
cheesy which is i'm gonna have three
questions i'm gonna ask you every day
you're gonna have to go full cheese
sandwich on this one and just own it
you're not her friend you're her mom own
mom own
full mom on this one and let her know
that you're in it with her
and then start asking her questions and
then just keep showing up and just keep
showing up and keep asking those
questions and she's not going to talk to
you she's going to i hate you oh my gosh
you keep showing up and keep showing up
and keep showing up what i mean by
showing up
every day you see her go grab her face
and say i'm your mom i'm gonna hold your
face for a second look her in the eye
and say i love you how is today
what's that boy's name i wanna hear it
how's your friend who's struggling how's
she doing
did you tell your friend that you loved
her today
put notes in her room write notes
whatever you got to do to
slowly relearn how to connect with your
kid
and make no mistake this is gonna be
hard because you're gonna have to walk
back a lot
you have to walk back an addiction
you're gonna have to walk back what she
feels is her
social connection to the world and this
will be
hopefully one of the greatest things
that ever happens between the two of you
especially if you live it out
it's going to be tough parents out there
follow
your gut a 14 year old cannot
self-regulate themselves
they can't they can't and
these devices
these companies are preying on your kid
for their data they're building
psychometric maps of your kid and that's
not woo
that's just they put that out there
that's documented and
man there are grown-ups college kids
high school kids who are preying on 14
year olds too
moms and dads your kids need you to be
firm and stand up in this
be the only parent it just takes a
little bit of courage
and then you're going to see people
around you slowly start to have more
courage and more courage and more
courage
and even if they don't do the right
thing remember what your mom said if
billy was jumping off a bridge would you
do it too
i'm doing that to you now you know it
you know it
it's not good for them they need you mom
and dad they need you
thank you so much for that call amy that
is a
conversation that's happening in
households all over the country and so
i'm grateful for your
vulnerability there time to turn around
let's do it all right let's go to
patrick in
jacksonville what's up patrick how are
we doing man how you doing i'm doing all
right
we're rocking and rolling on the ramsay
show it's uh
opportunity to talk to you on your show
i appreciate you taking my call
you got it brother so what's up man how
can i help
so i've been married for 11 years got
three kids my wife
i've been divorced twice i've had
problems in relationships and i'm trying
to make this one work
um hey hey i don't pause it right there
thank you for that patrick
thank you for that i've talked to too
many guys in your situation
that would roll their eyes and say yet
again i'm getting screwed on this deal
or i'm getting a hose on this deal or
whatever
and your first words to me are i'm
trying to make this work
and so i appreciate your vulnerability
there dude that takes a lot
is that new patrick uh it's it's
newish okay uh hey i've been i've been
trying to make it work on the uh on the
third time now
and the fourth and the fifth hey there
we go every day is a new chance to start
over all right man so how can i help
so the problem i have is i've come to
the end of my rope and i get angry and
mad and upset and frustrated and
want to nuke the whole thing and let go
but
i'm asked to hold on and i do
but i just feel like my wife's checked
out
yeah i would imagine so based on just
what you just told me
so i i i mean if
somebody who i loved and had chained
myself to it hitched myself to
got angry just wanted to cash out every
time yeah i would be checked out too i
mean i can imagine that's a
roller coaster and a whiplash so brother
why do you get angry and yell and scream
and
say i'm out i just feel like i'm
dragging this thing out by myself she
spends the majority of time i see her on
the back porch
scrolling on her phone or watching
videos and
i mean [ __ ] she hadn't sit down at the
dinner table me and the kids for over a
year
and how long have you been with her
we've been married 11
11 years okay so what is it about you
what is it about your family environment
that she wants no part of
i don't know you gotta know you've been
with over a decade
i think it's just distractions i know
but what does she need to distract
herself from
i don't know what about you
is she distracting herself from
accountability i mean i try to hold her
accountable for
responsibilities that she's not doing
and
okay give me an example of that
uh she's a stay-at-home mom she
has a hard time keeping up with the
house keeping up with the kids
keeping up with the kids clothes
routines
i mean it's gotten better but it's just
a challenge
to keep on task on track
to grow to be responsible to be
accountable to
say yeah i'm going to do this and then
it gets done
and it's i don't know what she's running
from i mean
we've had knock down drag outs we've had
reconciliations we've had
i left for 30 days and came back
because i didn't want to leave the
family yeah
but that was two three years ago
and i know she looks back on it and
this last anniversary was a good one and
we've made some steps but
i just don't see the work i don't see
the commitment i don't see the
the accountability the response i don't
see it how come your first marriage
didn't work brother
um i was young and stupid
elaborate got married uh i got married
as a young marine
uh deployed came back things were fast
and loose and it just
was stupid to get married in the first
place you didn't answer my question that
was
excellent evasion but you'd answer my
question did you cheat on her uh
yes yeah okay so why did your second
marriage work
uh she fell in love with somebody while
i was deployed okay came back got
married
she separated and married him okay
and what was it about this woman that
you're with now that made
giving it a third shot sound good
um well this one we got when we were
dating
again i was coming off my second
marriage and
going to the bars doing the thing and
ended up pregnant so
i wanted to make it work make sure that
my child had a
father and a mother um
and we considered abortion and we both
didn't want to do that
okay um and so we've we've pushed
through and we've had two more kids and
you know nine more years after that and
a couple houses new job
so i mean we've pushed
but you know
i'm sick of pushing yeah you know i can
hear that
and i promise you with everything i got
brother she's sick of being pushed
that's why i stopped pushing but leaving
it go and just kind of set
goals out there hasn't worked either i
mean i've separated bank accounts
because
the financial responsibility isn't there
um hey listen listen is she done
no that's the thing she she says she's
not done she wants to work it out she
wants
she wants to keep working okay and the
way you've described your
wife to me as though you're describing a
teenage daughter
that you can't get under control
feel that way she is no more your
partner in raising family
and just trying to suck the joy
out of life the the
wreckage that life is just misery after
misery and that's what partners can
do for each other when their marriage is
just rad as they just find
joy is you have put her in line with one
as another child and you might feel like
you have to
but she's another kid with goals and
expectations and achievements that she
needs to accomplish in order to
make sure your house looks the way it
needs to be and that your her body looks
the way it needs to be and your sex life
needs to be in your part
all those things and at some point she
checked out
possibly early on
and for most of us i don't want to over
gender this but most of our
us men we know one thing and that's to
push harder
and if we're losing a fight then we
think we need to
swing harder and kick harder and go for
takedowns harder
and you just said it perfectly i'm tired
of pushing man and i want to honor that
this relationship can handle no more
pushing
and if you back up 10 steps 15 steps and
you
look at this woman not as a problem to
fix
or as somebody to get in line but as
somebody to sit next to and hold their
hand and say baby i'm so sorry can we we
got to start over from square one
and what you got now is a relationship
that's over 10 years
right so y'all are in a tough window you
got three kids how old are your kids
uh six nine and ten oh brother y'all are
in it
right you've got five thousand
activities all day every day
some kids running in there yelling and
screaming the other kids saying
everybody shut up and there's
moods everywhere right you're in it
right
and you've got this woman who's at home
who's desperate to be seen
and known and to be loved at a
vulnerable level
and she's being given tasks and when she
fails the tasks you take away the task
and say i'll do it myself you see how
she's almost as though she's a member of
one of your units
instead of your wife i do but i've taken
those away i used to do that and i've
stopped and i've
asked her what her goals are what she
wants to accomplish what she's trying to
do to grow
i've tried to include her in the
conversation to include
include her in you know her finances
getting her
stuff in order on her own time on her
own accord
i i've stopped pushing i've stopped
dragging i've stopped
other than me being attached to the
relationship
is what i feel like i'm dragging now how
do you bring her joy
how do you how do you inject joy and
safety into her life besides the fact
that you're an ex-marine you can kick
people's ass like
how do you how do you inject joy and
safety into her life
i mean i try to spend time with her um
dedicate every tuesday to her okay try
to and what is it
what does that dedication look like
coaching opportunities
no just spending time with her i mean
the five love languages quality time and
words of affirmation are hurt okay so i
try to
when she does cook dinner when she does
get dressed up or get dressed i try to
acknowledge it when
you know so i try to feed her her love
language and
but you see how you've just those two
examples when she achieves and does the
right things
then i let her know
she's not your child brother she's your
wife
and so here's the status of your
relationship okay
and i don't want you to mistake me i
know you love this lady and i know that
you really want to do this right
and there's a sacred moment when a guy
realizes
i'm trying to fix this engine in my car
and all i have is a wrench and a hammer
and these two tools aren't working oh
and by the way she's not an engine
in a car right and there's a
humility a humbleness a vulnerability
which is the anti-marine move right it
that's rolling over on your stomach and
on your back and
exposing your belly and saying you could
hurt me hun
but i have to tell you i'm out of tools
and i am going to go
learn some new tools i would love for
you to come with me
and she's probably not going to go man
when's the last time
you went and started talking to a
counselor on some new tools to help you
be a better man and a better husband a
better dad
i went to a counselor on my own i mean
told had it
mobile right but i talked to a counselor
for about three months and
i got the advice that she is who she is
her past
her past actions are gonna be your
future actions and you've got to come to
terms with it or
yeah i get a new counselor that one
sucks
sucks yeah the counselor is terrible
counselor i mean it kind of stuck with
me but
that's not that doesn't help every
single person can change
but they can only change if they have if
they are tethered into something
bigger and stronger than themselves
and it sounds like your wife is
exhausted
and detached because all she's been is a
series of
accomplishments achievements failures
she's got to live up to the standards of
her marine husband
and here's the thing here's the truth
you know that if
fill in the blank if she got control of
her money if she exercised if she ate
differently
if she fill in the blank that those
things would help her
but she's got to come to those things on
her own
and she has to hear those things from
somebody that she can actually hear him
from
and she's got to be tethered into you
for connection right
she does not need any more information
from you she needs you
and so here's what you're gonna i want
you to keep this picture and i've used
this image a bunch i'm gonna continue to
use it because
it works you guys have
a relationship that's ten plus years old
three kids
right you're gonna have to excavate what
you have
right now and rebuild something from the
floor up and if she won't participate in
the early rounds of
the architecture and design cool
but i'd love for you guys to sit down
and
just dream together is this is this what
this is going to be for us
are we going to be back porch scrolling
through instagram for the rest of like
what
what do you need what can what can i
what can
how can i bring you joy and you can't
make her do anything your counselor was
right on that
but what you can do is inject joy into
your home
and that comes from you doing the things
that you can control you working on your
thoughts your actions your behaviors
your way of treating people in the world
not lecturing her on what she eats but
you being a model
not lecturing around you know what you
should be doing you should be exercising
getting your finances right
but instead bringing your three kids
around for a budget day hooray
and bringing i don't know reese's peanut
butter cups or whatever is going to make
your kids excited about it you're going
to teach them how to budget
and you're going to do it with joy and
with laughter and with fun
not with military precision military
precision is important
but only when you have full trust does
that work
when you've signed it all over and your
wife's not signed on anymore
she's not signed on anymore and so
what's the best way
i mean you're headed towards if you're
not there already towards bitter
bitter resentment and then it's hard to
come back from that man
and so i want you to go about wooing
your wife again
i want you to go about finding the
things that
that get you all fired up to get your
heart beating again
that excites you about your kids excite
you about joy and love in your house
i want you to find another counselor
because the one you talk to sucks anyone
who says well it's just the way it's
going to be you have to get used to
it terrible terrible you either leave
or you both grow together and i think
every single person can grow
a hundred percent of them if they have
attached
relationships if they are anchored into
something solid
right and dude i know you're tired man i
so know you're tired of hearing your
voice
so stop working on her and i want you to
start working on you
and i want you to reverse engineer your
life find the places where you can be
patient where you can be kind where you
laugh
a lot right where you forgive other
people including yourself
where you don't you don't identify with
the worst things you've done
the stupidest things you've said and the
dumbest decisions you've made but you
identify with the future where you're
taking these kids
how are you going to love this woman i
want you to grow that way brother
and there's a big awesome world there i
want you to grab a book
called i don't want to talk about it by
terence real we'll put it in the show
notes we'll link to it
but i want you to on amazon today i want
you to read that book
and if you're not a big reader get the
audio book and start from there
okay i don't want to talk about it by
terry real terence real
man thank you so much for that call
patrick i know that's hard brother i
know that's hard here's the
the the 30 000 foot ultimate umbrella
statement you can't fix her
you can fix you what i promise you is
if she's really in watching you
infuse and inject and create a platform
of joy and love in your home
with those kids a safe place that's not
a repair manual
but just someone loves her she's gonna
say hey
something's different something's new
what's going on right and then you gotta
have in your head your or what moment
man at some point you gotta say i'm out
i know you feel shame that you failed
once you fail twice
i get that but you're gonna have to keep
that line for yourself too man
because you don't to drag your kids down
you don't drag this woman down any
further
hey i want to take a quick break and
talk about something important
your mental health if you cannot find an
in-person counselor in your area or you
can't afford one i've got a solution
i've partnered with better help for
customized online therapy
for you video chat phone or even
text chat counseling with licensed
therapists
that are going to help you become a
better version of yourself
help you get on the road to being well
go to betterhelp.com deloney for ten
percent off your first
month this is less expensive than
traditional therapy and you're
worth it betterhelp.com
take care of yourself start today
all right this is john with the dr john
deloni's show we're going back to the
phones let's go to
morgan in kingman arizona morgan what's
going on
hi dr dolany thank you so much for
having me thank you for calling how in
the world are you
good how are you good good good all
right so what's up how can i help you
okay so we just became a first time
foster family a few months ago to a
newborn baby yeah dude congratulations
thank you what a hate um that's a long
arduous road
you are hard a hero without a cave it is
super hard
do you have your own kids i do how many
you got
i have a i have a seven-year-old or a
yeah seven-year-old boy and a
nine-year-old girl
oh my you are changing
legacy oh thank you listen
i know you feel like uh things that all
the trains have derailed
everywhere but listen what you are doing
for those two kids
your biological kids what are you doing
for that
foster kid what you're doing for your
marriage is
messy and bananas and extraordinary
thank you thank you thank you thank you
all right so what's your question thank
you
so my question is this is our first
foster baby we want to do foster care
for a long time
um i am terrified to say goodbye to this
little one
and the main goal of foster care is
reunification which i think is great
um that sounds super good until you hold
that baby right
it is it's so hard and i i just think
about
not seeing him again and i don't know
how i'm gonna do it and how my kids
like how i'm gonna help my kids through
that so i'm wondering if you have any
advice for
any tools yes so i
actually um i've got several close
friends who have
i've just been able to watch navigate
this for 10 15 years some of them and so
um yeah there's some tough lessons
learned and some beautiful things that
have
come from this it's hard to see when
you're in the middle of this
banana season right um you
said the most important thing that's
hard to get people to turn to
which is what is my number one job
and it's to hold and love
and model the love for this baby knowing
that the single most important person in
his life is not me
and that is so hard to do right
right and i know that mentally yeah yes
i'm trying to get there emotionally
so i want you to be really graceful with
yourself
especially with with baby number one
baby number two baby number three this
is so so hard
so let me ask you a few questions about
this do you have any connection to
baby's mom or dad are you a part of
helping them with services
can you be i
can be
the only reason i'm not is
i have two little ones of my own and
i have no judgment towards family
whatsoever
but i get a little nervous bringing
people into our lives that i don't know
sure so if that makes sense
yes and you've brought a baby into your
life
and so you've brought an entire family
system into your life
and so you can't um you can't bring this
baby in
you can't take the good parts without
the scary parts that's true good parts
of this little baby the scary part so
there's there an
entire family system that if it were
working perfectly
this kid would not be in this situation
right so
one or two of my friends who have done
this beautifully
have actually taken the
hearts and minds of the family this
baby's moving back into
into consideration so they have offered
things like
parenting like parenting coaching for
the mom or the or the dad
regular coffee visits how are you doing
and here's what happens over time most
not always
but most of the time parents will take
you up on that because they're desperate
and they will see something that you
have that they don't which is peace
right peace in the only chaotic
peace that a mother of a nine and a
seven year old have right
which is not day to day peace not sleep
not hair looks good or my makeup is all
crazy
but that piece that knows this is right
you know what i mean
and so offering hey i'll meet with you
once every two weeks i'm gonna get a
babysitter for my kids or while they're
in school we're gonna go meet for coffee
somewhere
and if you don't feel comfortable yet in
your home that's great that's no problem
but it will give you a sense of empathy
for them too because they've got a story
to tell as well
so i'm gonna tell you about a
conversation i had in grad school that
was a healing moment for me
um it was a moment of shame for me and
then a moment of healing and so
i was working as in a placement with an
extraordinary psychologist who just
worked with traumatized kids
and we had just left another situation
where a mom
was not working her services and in my
head
had chosen drugs over her kid that's how
i had framed
this thing and i was so angry and i was
running my mouth
and he gently turned to me and said and
i said something along the lines some
patriot like patronizing man i can't
believe that
whatever mom chose whatever instead of
that beautiful little kid
and the psychologist just said to me man
if you knew mom's story
meth makes a lot of sense her life has
been
hell and just that one sentence of
man if you knew her story you have no
idea
right and it instantly made me feel
ridiculous for running my mouth
about a mother who i didn't know
comparing her situation to mine i had a
newborn and i thought i was all high and
mighty
but what it really did was it set me on
a rabbit hole
in of empathy how can i hear other
people's stories and hear what's going
on in their hearts and minds and how can
i be a part of that narrative not the
blaming and shaming and screaming and
yelling at people narrative
and so listen once i started hearing
these stories
oh my gosh seven drinks makes a lot of
sense man
you know what i mean and it helped me
navigate a whole new it helped open my
eyes to a whole new thing so i'm telling
you
you your first thoughts are i'm not
judging but
we're all we've all been there okay i
think it would do your
soul a world of good to offer and they
may not take you up on it and you'll get
frustrated by it
and but you're gonna get to see another
side of a human being's story and you
may get to pass along some great skills
and here's
all of this is headed towards this a lot
of these families are still in
connection with my friends
the kids are still in connection their
parents are so
grateful for the human connection
because they have court they have the
mandated counseling
they've got the a meetings have to
attend they don't have any relationships
and that are outside of the family or
drugs or whatever and
whoa what a gift you can be morgan okay
so here's here's another thing
and my friend slade has has taught me
this and
i have never done it so i'm just talking
to you third hand okay
he says they own the collective grief
every time as a family
they take the kid back it just hurts
and it stinks and there is something so
beautiful and legacy changing about
teaching your children
modeling for your children that
relationship is risk and relation
relationships include
pain and it hurts
and it's worth it
right that's a really good way to look
at it yeah so
what i didn't know until i was married
for 10 years was that relationships suck
and they're really hard
when i started thinking of exit
strategies right
and you will have given your kids an
understanding of no no relationships are
really hard and they're good and they're
worth it and they're so awful and you
cry
and and and they're still right
and you will get to honor your kids that
and there is no magic sauce for that
there's just lots and lots and lots of
hugs
uh slade who's like a super in shape
like he was my workout partner for years
he talked about they dropped off one of
their kids
and they just made their way to a taco
bell which is not a food him and his
family would normally eat
and he said they were they were just
silent and then the person in front of
them just mysteriously paid for their
mini van full of
people and he said there was some moment
of grace there they all cried they all
laughed and there was just this
collection
collective this sucks but we're gonna be
okay and let's go help somebody else
does that make sense
yeah so i guess i i need to get past my
i'm very like positive everything's okay
everything's good we'll be fine
no and maybe you need to get more into
the heaviness of it
that it's going to suck well and you
will be fine
right and you'll be fine yeah and
relationship is worth the pain
right and it just because it hurts
doesn't mean it's wrong
and our kids are grown up in a world
where discomfort has been
pathologized right discomfort has been
made the bad guy and it's not
right discomfort's just a signal that we
really loved hard and it hurts
what a magical gift you'll give to them
and
bring them along for this ride let them
know hey
it's their foster baby too they get to
help with breakfast and diapers
and reading stories oh my gosh
you are giving them
oh thank you they're awesome helpers yep
they love this little baby and
it's been great awesome so listen don't
ever
let them catch you talking bad about the
other family
no i never do don't ever let them catch
you
trying to hide emotions just be just
live and love recklessly in front of
them
and let them absorb all of you all of
this baby
and man what a gift you're giving them
what a gift you are giving them giving
them there is no way to make this not
hard
it's just hard right
you've given me a great perspective of
where to go with it well and i
really really want you to think about
channeling into a conversation
or a meeting a regular connection with
um this baby's mom and or this baby's
dad
if if it's safe and the courts will
allow it i would love to see you reach
out and do that
it's going to be clarifying for you and
along the way
if you really believe reunification is
the best and that's where you got to be
it's where you got to be and i know you
look at your house and you think nobody
could love this baby like i do
you also have your two kids and you know
that nobody can love your two kids like
you can
right right and so that little baby's
got a mom and a daddy out there
somewhere
right and they're loving sideways and
crooked and they are broken and
stumbling
but that right place for that kid unless
there is pain
and hurt is with their mom and dad and
so
man you can teach them hey they really
love this this baby
loves this and laughs when you do this
and loves happiness
you could be such a bridge to that
family and a
gift that will be legacy i mean family
tree changing for
your family and theirs and for everybody
listening
foster parents are absolute rock star
heroes it
is the hardest thing
whether you're fostering to adopt or
you're just doing foster appearing you
are opening up your heart
with full understanding that there is
hurt on the other end for you
best case scenario the kid leaves and it
hurts
worst case scenario parents aren't able
to complete their services or choose not
to complete their services or whatever
the baby has to move on to a foster home
you're hurt
but in the middle you get to
model for a baby that they have value
they're worth being loved you get to
model for a middle schooler that's
never had somebody look them in the eye
and say you have worth
you get to take little snapshots in
history and plant
seeds in kids hearts oh my gosh and it
is hard hard hard and it is holy holy
good
great work if you've ever thought about
fostering please consider doing that
please consider doing that
all right so as we wrap up today's show
man you know what we're going back
to 2010. the album is called how i got
over
you don't think the roots need to invite
anybody but they did they invited john
legend on this
track called the fire and it goes like
this
yeah and if i'm ever at the crossroads
and start feeling mixed signals like
morse code my soul starts to grow colder
than the north pole
i try to focus on the whole of where the
torch goes
in the tradition of these legendary
sports pros as far as i can see
i've made it to the threshold lord knows
i've waited for
this a lifetime and i'm an icon where i
let my light
shine and there's something in your
heart and it's in your eyes it's the
fire inside you let it burn
you don't say good luck you say don't
give up
it's the fire inside you let it burn the
roots with john legend
this has been the dr john deloney show